all right
oh a greenish shirt on a green screen
background it's either gonna work or
it's not
I don't want to change I'm going to
power through it hopefully it works out
[Music]
missing or searching it's missing
searching is the movie that came out in
2018 cool so missing is a missing
person's film like the movie searching
that came out in 2018. it stars storm
read for about well I mean it starts her
for 100 of the film but she is the one
on screen for easily about 90 of the
film and like the movie
searching I just checked this this is
going to bother you and I apologize for
that I have gotten missing and searching
mixed up in my head all day long I feel
like it's just not gonna stop missing is
formatted like the film searching where
the entire investigation it's through
screen shares and Screen recordings and
apps which makes sense because directors
Nicholas Johnson and will Merrick were
editors on searching before I get to the
execution of the film I will say storm
read did an excellent job it's heartfelt
it's emotional and she has to convey
these emotions single-handedly to the
audience she was excellent you don't
have a lot of actors bouncing off of
each other as I mean they do in the
sense of Skype calls and whatnot or
other FaceTime or phone apps that my old
man energy ass doesn't I don't know
about it has supporting actors in it but
if she didn't stick The Landing the
movie wouldn't have worked on the other
hand if the investigation isn't
interesting also if this movie wouldn't
have worked it enthralled me to the
point where I couldn't take my eyes off
of the screen and then I was baffled
that it was even that interesting I
don't know why because missing was nope
searching
this is why I check 2018 searching was
every bit as enthralling so I shouldn't
be surprised that missing was as well
and a lot of it is in the hands of the
editing again the directors of this film
were editors on Miss Missing ah
searching the directors of missing were
editors on searching and in both cases
the editing is just it's actually quite
incredible the editing the jumping in
between apps when they're doing things
that we all hate to do like recover a
missing password who likes doing that
nobody but they either Fast Track
through it or use it as there's a moment
of humor in there it's just personality
in the editing it makes the characters
relatable and all we're seeing is what
they are doing on a computer also she's
typing she's texting someone trying to
get information and there's that person
is responding text on the bottom and it
goes away and then it comes back and it
just shows the pause that the person on
the other end had moments like that make
you feel like she is talking to a human
being and you're thinking to yourself
like did she freak him out are they
going to give her bad information now it
keeps attention alive it makes people
we're not even seeing on camera feel
human could have just had you know text
come up and that was that but that
wouldn't feel human got to give props
for that the devil's in the details this
is a film that thrives with detail and
yeah the twist turns the mystery it
keeps coming it keeps unraveling you're
really watching this thing unfold you
don't know what the next move is going
to be she feels lost at times you feel
lost because she feels lost but I
watched an entire film of someone
talking through an app and their screen
recordings I was engaged the entire time
there was a point in this film where I
was like did this movie just jump the
shark yeah I feel like it did give it a
couple minutes
and it makes sense it works itself out I
don't tell you this as a critique I tell
you this so when you're watching this
movie you can be like what wait Jeremy
said give it a couple minutes we'll see
or you won't and you'll be like yeah
he's wrong about that that's why I'm not
subscribed to this guy I don't know if
that's the case um thanks for checking
this out but in the end I thought
missing was great I'm surprised more
movies horror or otherwise haven't used
this format you know we never saw that
true saturation of the market like we
did with found footage you could use
this format to show movies where people
hunt for UFOs or investigate corrupt and
crooked politicians you can do a hundred
things with it felt like I gave
Hollywood the green light like yeah you
know the elevation of found foot yeah
just go ahead and run that into the
ground until you make complete and utter
dog [ __ ] with it and people get sick of
it and tell you to stop I'm just
spitballing that's what I do I spitball
and I ruined genres I thought this was
an incredibly gripping and engaging
mystery I was interested and I always
wanted to see what happened next I had
myself a great time no alcohol required
the real mystery is the transformation
of January it's been a pretty incredible
month in terms of entertainment which
makes me wonder in a world where
everything has a price wins the ax gonna
drop on this when are we gonna get this
weeks months long dry spell of dog [ __ ]
I don't know but for now this is a
January of a different tune I like it so
missing have you seen it what did you
think about it what's the elevation of
the found footage genre for you whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]